[Music]
oh my God private get to the bomb
shelter solivan are we up to date on
supplies private sir yes sir sir we have
a full 30-day Supply from prepare with
cr.com sir a 30-day pre-made Supply food
kit that sounds like a ripoff Sullivan
sir no sir thanks to prepareth cr.com we
got 30 days with the food ship free $99
thanks to prepare withth cr.com that
Supply was Shi 30 days $99 free why that
does sound like a good deal you might
not be totally useless after all tell me
does that kit include the broccoli
cheddar cheese soup I love so much yes
sir right here for you sir and how about
those dehydrated Banas and oatmeal sir
yes sir right here for you sir and how
about that chocolate pudding that's
better than store
bought private
private private I eat the pudding sir
you what I E the pudding FR repl
sir Mission Control s more py Mission
Control I'm got to replace the py
mission control zenar pting Mission
Control
zar now come over here
private get yourself
together now go and replace that
chocolate
pudding oh
no prepare with
[Applause]
crowder.edu
[Music]
that's what I
know I
strange I
[Music]
follow
spe
[Music]
that's the ancient art of Kata by the
way for people before you complain this
is unloaded I was showing my producers
here I did a trigger job on my Ruger SP
101 fantastic firearm uh huge show today
by the way first off producing with me
in video Studio as always is Jared who
is not gay follow him at Twitter on
Twitter notgay Jared me s Crowder I
fulfill my legal obligations drawing on
conclusions we good we're good thank you
Gerald is back in the seat Morgan Jr
worst Twitter handle in the business
thank you very much and apparently
Edward the sound guy is now foni did you
see that
hey we got Razer Ramone on sound hey y
I'm a bad guy uh Big Show Big Show we
have Dr Dr Jordan Peterson back we'll be
talking about uh we took your questions
so of course today is the live show by
the way for those who want The Daily
Show lc.com mugclub some huge shows this
week uh big debates behind the pay wall
that we would never be allowed to have
on YouTube and um Jordan Peterson and we
have uh one of the best comedians
working today Owen Benjamin many of you
know him love him very funny and uh a
little more outspoken about his
political views yes yeah I think it's
coming I think it's 20 2017 is creating
culture where that's becoming okay it's
becoming okay which which is good to see
yeah it's a conservative coming out Year
yes in a matter of speaking but every
year is Jared's coming out own ABC show
one day speaking of coming out
faith-based gay group uh I don't know if
you saw this this is in the news we'll
get to other news after this but I
thought this was most pressing to
address faith-based gay group did you
see this uh for Ash Wednesday coming up
to Easter they put glitter do we have
that they put glitter in the ashes yeah
right there uh we have it right there
they put glitter in the ashes uh I don't
know why it's some kind of a statement
and people are mad about it but uh
honestly I think they're being rather
merciful uh compared with their original
plan of replacing lent candles with butt
plugs I don't think
that's welcome to Thursday welcome to
Thursday so Nows
um uh Valerie Jarrett did you read about
this Valerie Jarrett is moving in with
the Obamas this was a big thing was
trending all day today Valerie Jarrett
is moving in with the Obama most Trusted
Senior adviser moving into their DC home
um and this is because they speculation
they have a plan to enter sort of
liberal politics and create these think
tanks you know the only thing worse than
a Jimmy Carter presidency is is Jimmy
Carter post president yes I think that's
rush rush limbo who said it I don't know
who says it my dad says it all the time
when he's yelling at the TV without
pants his post
presidency um so Valerie Jarrett by the
way who whose family we know are open
Communists from FBI documents this is
important to note um valer jarett's
daughter was also recently hired by CNN
to cover Trump in the Justice Department
did you know this so valer Jarrett
moving with the Obamas Valerie Jarrett's
daughter hired to CNN to cover Donald
Trump and and uh first off it will make
one hell of a
sitcom the OB that's our communist noted
communist and daughter working with CNN
and people wonder why Americans don't
trust the media these days we'll get
into that more as far as all the
[Laughter]
relationships don't miss it I know I
didn't know about that one world
premiere World premier TVs they have to
compete with Tyler Perry That's not easy
not easy right there the leading is
Media says learn um CNN hires her
daughter moving in with the Obamas I it
gets to a certain point with Chris Cuomo
with Wolf Blitzer Jarrett hired at cenn
you've got to wonder what the hiring
practices are even like there all right
well thanks for coming in it's been
great talking to you I really appreciate
it you've got some great experience here
you've worked a lot of uh great news
organizations done some good stuff yeah
yeah thank you we're going to talk about
this and I'll be in touch after I
discuss with some people but I really oh
really yeah yeah no kidding no yeah yeah
oh you're hired really yeah oh wow
you're good thanks for coming in we
appreciate that yeah no it's good to
have you here bright future all right
thank you I don't know how we get all
this exclusive footage from the
offices this part of the leaks we really
I mean tell you what your support of the
mug Club is really leading uh to a level
of
professionalism
unparalleled anywhere on youtube.com/
Steven Crowder I don't really know at
this point the one thing is you know we
we've talked about this before but I
don't think people know how entrenched
the media is with the DNC and
particularly with the clintons we can go
through a few examples here uh George
Stephanopoulos now a lot of young people
don't know this about George
Stephanopoulos look at that first off
he's the third member of Sig freed and
Roy he's going to be dragged out by a
tiger and a leotard very soon uh he was
Bill Clinton's communications director
MH he was the Democratic party adviser
now you know this I know this but a lot
of people who watch the show who are
younger don't know that this is a guy
who's hosting ABC News he's a host of
this week literally worked for the
clintons you don't need a conspiracy you
don't need to talk about Chemtrails or
John podesta uh with little boys in his
basement at a pizza parlor this actually
happened Donna Brazil Donna Brazil of
course Al gor's campaign manager twice
the interim chairperson for the DNC
caught sneaking debate questions to
Hillary Clinton worked for CNN openly
working for CNN as a correspondent Chuck
Todd Chuck Todd rat campaign staffer
worked on 92 sorry worked to 92
presidential I was going to say worked
to 92 presidential campaigns he
impressive he he must moisturize goetter
he worked n for the 92 I don't know I
must have had a stroke today my mouth is
not working the point is the guy's a
Democrat the point is the guys worked
for the DNC the point is the guy worked
in the 92 presidential campaign and of
course you know he works over there at
NBC Chuck Todd and our favorite resident
pool Boy and Chief Chris Cuomo Chris
Cuomo of course has his own show at CNN
and he's the son of the famed New York
uh Democrat Governor Mario Cuomo brother
of the current governor Andrew Cuomo you
know this right yeah Gerald Cuomo's
everywhere I do I tweeted him I don't
know this is a genuine question does
Chris Cuomo actually still think he's a
news anchor or does he consider himself
an opinion journalist I don't know he's
got to it's got to be opinion right he
has to know that I think he considers
himself a news anchor and and uh you
know the reason for this from the left
is they operate from this basis I think
from Chris Kum the only way he could
consider himself a news anchor and not
an opinion journalist when he's more
opinionated more slanted than this show
we're just we're incredibly biased don't
get me wrong but at least we try to
admit it and explain it and explore what
kind of bias we have and where we might
be wrong Chris colan doesn't even allow
room for that and I think he would
consider himself a news anchor as
opposed to opinion journalist because
today's Progressive left it's not
necessarily facts or statistics based
but it's just you know what I know the
way Society should work it should be
this way therefore news you know there
are 37 genders therefore every single
boy who wants to compete as a girl or
girl who wants to take stage should win
female wrestling state titles we know
that Society should work where uh
marriages between whoever wants it to be
therefore this is news we know George
Bush was a war criminal therefore news
we know Hillary Clinton was supposed to
be the first female president therefore
news and their opinion now if you base
it on that Foundation of I know how
Society should work in New York City
better than you do then you consider it
all news yeah even as entrenched as I
think we are in our ideas we hold this
principle that maybe we're going to be
wrong and we probably won't know it when
we are wrong right so listening to other
people that have a different opinion is
pretty good it is a good idea uh when
asked for his opinion uh as to why
people believed he wasn't a legitimate
journalist uh Chris K had this to say oh
man oh god oh man oh god oh man oh god
oh man
he calm down Chris Cuomo worked up he
worked up he gets himself too worked up
and I do as much as I don't like him I
worry about the man's health I I do
think and you know talking about that
too this idea exploring it a little
deeper that news reporters who fany
themselves Arbiters of how Society
should work therefore everything's
acceptable as news as opposed to opinion
there's this idea that there was a
golden age of Journalism and I I don't
know I feel like I'm one of the few
people who maintains that never actually
existed there was never a golden age of
Journalism certainly not since the 70s
Walter kite's as bad as anyone there's
ever been he's just as bad as Cuomo I
mean Walter kronite said you can't be a
reporter and be a liberal you can find
the quote very easily but people fancy
him as this unbiased journalist I don't
think there's ever I don't think human
beings are capable of unbiased news um
this is entirely my opinion that's why I
have much more respect for people who
are open about something on which
they're incredibly biased and say this
this is how I justify that worldview
because I feel as Chris CUA Wolf Blitzer
uh take your pick they're all trying to
justify the worldview they're all trying
to reinforce it but some do so under the
guys of news am I am I alone in that no
I respect people that give me an
opportunity to see a reasonable case
made for somebody else's opinion even
though I may disagree and think they're
idiots yeah but it's a reasonable
presentation not like some nut job on
the left or the right yeah so I think I
think you're it's important by the way
to see the difference note the
difference nak jar talked about this
during the the show uh pitch meeting
where he was much more talkative than
today apparently a cat literally scraped
out his tongue he's like that that that
dummy lady in dead silent um no one here
watches horror movies that's right
you're old pansies I forgot about this
you all hide under the covers and watch
reruns of fre company which is also why
you're under the covers Suzanne
Summers um wow and then you have these
people who come in and they throw these
buzzwords out this is what worries me a
little bit about the modern sort of
alt-right Quasi conservative populism
movement where people go oh man
corporate media now we just exposed we
just talked about the media and how
biased they are um and I totally agree
with that but if you threw out the
corporate media yeah that's a problem
but you would prefer government media I
mean you have these same people out
there who have Trump in their in their
Avatar Pepe the Frog and they go BBC man
or NPR that's are you out of your tree
sir BBC government funded media we
talked about this Canada literally had
two parties NDP and the Liberal Party
Justin Trudeau won I can't remember who
promised what I think it was Justin trau
promised another $100 million to CBC the
Canadian the Govern government funded
news entity in Canada uh if he won guess
who won Justin Trudeau smart man and for
some reason people assume NPR is somehow
unbiased just because they're boring
that's one thing too if you say people
like to assume passion equals dishonesty
right and somehow if you're sitting
there talking about you know your
lesbian folk Trio on NPR that people oh
you know this is unbiased and that's one
thing if you guys have been listening to
NPR they have the worst slant of anyone
out there if you think that is damn fine
reporting you need a cat scan it's the
exact same thing where it just they
operate under the assumption of the
liberal premise right they operate under
the assumption of well gender of course
has nothing to do with uh biology one's
gender is not determined by one's sex
and they'll go on you're like if you
just don't understand what you're
hearing you go yeah NPR sounds like
they're factual because this I mean why
would why would they broadcast anything
this boring if it weren't
factual want to see the number of car
wrecks associated with NPR listenership
yes yes exactly I fell asleep officer
although and you know same thing too we
can't compete with NPR's podcast
everyone's like oh their their podcast
serial is always at the top well of
course it's at the top no one else these
are independent podcast we can't compete
against a nevering supply of federal
funding it's like Cal is number one oh
how much did you get from the government
19 trillion zillion dollars I can see
why yeah well no wonder you're beating
Joe Rogan dicks my point is this uh I I
really think it's just important instead
of just under the blind assumption that
this person is biased this person is not
biased we always tell that we are biased
but be aware of what you're watching and
be able to parse it yourselves if you
look at the connection with the media
there's no denying that they lean left
but the same thing if you tune in to a
Shan Hannity who at this point
effectively acts as a surrogate for
Donald Trump and I like Donald Trump and
I actually like Shan Hannity you need to
be aware of what you're watching the
golden age in journalism I don't think
it ever existed I just don't think
people were aware of what it was that
they were consuming we'll talk more
about that after this break than Jordan
beers in and Owen Benjamin my voice is
going hi that mean a
[Music]
break welcome to another installment of
the reasonable conversationalist on NPR
this week we are joined by William Jared
Valerie Jared's husband thank you for
being with us William thank you for
having me now William um of course
you've been uh working with your wife in
politics for years on uh on the equal
rights on which we all agree for the
LGBT TQ AI Community correct yes that's
correct fascinating and and truly is a
civil rights uh uh struggle of our time
uh on which all Americans can agree how
can we uh best move forward of course in
in uh assuring that none of us will for
example misgender one of the current 57
available offerings well I just think
that you should probably ask them what
they prefer to be called well that
sounds entirely reasonable join us again
next week for another installment of the
reasonable conversationalist on npl
[Music]
wish we could
go just CL my
[Music]
eyes I call that my Edward sound guy
dance hey hey
hey that's not that's not going he was
inspired by this so he was just pointing
pistols at you yes at G Morgan not it's
not very nice it's not at this point I
actually have a pistol in my office
aimed squarely at Ed the sound it's on a
stand a but I don't want to aim that's
the truth you're never supposed to aim a
gun at somebody but if you have a gun in
a room anywhere it's always aimed at
somebody oh yeah I always cross the
front of mine in the bathroom
technically it would go through the wall
right but it's there right and I feel
better about it I see better I see
better knowing it's there my AR15 would
take out the pool guy he wouldn't even
see it coming awesome it's aimed at the
wall like it's aimed at the wall it's
not aimed at anybody if it's a at Edward
it's aimed at me too it's true yeah son
of a yeah it's loaded with hollow point
38s at this point it's not going to over
penetrate Edward's a Edward's a thick
enough fell 39 caliber magazine yeah if
it were Jared sitting there that would
be Nota J with that' be much more of a
problem you'd both be taken out yeah
yeah that's true it'd be like going
through magazine and then into a
paperback but in this case Edward would
stop it uh speaking about the media and
and
listen I'm amazed if the media wants to
talk about you know being banned right
CNN they were they were banned uh we'll
talk about that later I'm amazed that
there's no commentary right now on this
on this from Europe do you see this with
Marie Le Pen oh jeez so Marie Le Pen uh
France obviously listen undoubtedly a
flawed human being Marie Le Pen so first
off don't expect us to defend everything
that Mar Le Pen has done but this story
here for those who don't understand uh
let me clarify for you let me break this
down so that then we can talk about it
in 2015 Leen tweeted out some gruesome
pictures of what Isis actually does MH
specifically what they did to uh the
American reporter um Foley that's it
James Foley so the Socialist left in
Europe Europe European Parliament just
voted to retroactively now there's
there's immunity I guess applied to
certain people to politicians uh where
you're not allowed to post certain kinds
of images basically it's an infringement
on Free Speech there is an immunity that
applies to uh certain politicians to to
certain figure heads in Europe okay so
this applied to Marie Leen it applied to
Marie Leen in 2015 when she tweeted
these images out European Parliament
elected to
retroactively remove her immunity so
they can now prosecute her for a crime
in 2015 which was totally legal in 2015
and what was her Crime Free Speech Free
Speech tweeting out something that
actually happened they weren't
classified pictures they weren't
anything like that it was it was it was
public yeah they weren't classified
pictures yeah you could you could
actually find the images on Google she
didn't know who it was at the time that
she was tweeting out and when the family
contacted her she immediately removed it
right so she she did everything right it
seems well listen and again she's a
flawed person I don't know where her
heart was with that but she has a real
problem with Islamic terrorism as do I
and she was trying to Showcase them for
the evil that they are you'd be in jail
yeah I would be in jail definitely would
be in jail well if I were in Europe yeah
so let's apply this to the United States
and again you know you have the you have
the medeia with CNN and they're were
Furious that they weren't allowed into
Trump's uh uh impromptu press conference
he called it an impromptu press Gaggle
and I talked about that Monday have a
problem with it I think CNN is
incredibly biased but as a conservative
I don't believe that we should be in the
business of banning any voices I want to
see more rather than Banning CNN or
Politico or New York Times I'd love to
see Donald Trump keep them there and
then include new voices that's what I
want to see so I talked about that I
I've tried to be consistent with that
but if CN is going to complain about not
being allowed into an impromptu press
gaggle
let's if this were in the United States
let's apply what this were imagine that
you in 2015 committed an entirely legal
act okay you spoke out you spoke out and
you said something that was unpopular
wasn't even racist but it was based on
something that had actually happened uh
a news event that was offensive picture
this you did that in 2015 it's entirely
legal today because people don't like
what you have to say political opponents
retroactively vote to make that
illegal and remove your ability to speak
freely based on something you did in
2015 Pam Peller would be in jail sale
before noon yes yeah and not the padded
room that some would suggest um I
actually like Pamela Galler but when she
appears on media she she sometimes she
seems she's like she's like what yes you
know I mean you're like whoa easy calm
down you quomo you and quomo need to get
in the same relaxation program are you
amazed that we haven't heard no one's
talking about this I'm shocked because
this is this is only a political hit job
so you can ask the European Union can be
asked to take away the immunity from
anybody who's not performing
parliamentary functions right if it's an
illegal thing that's what they did they
said this is not a parliamentary
function that she was performing yeah
she spoke out by the way Parliament
serves no function continue that's true
so I guess this is an oxymoron yeah
whatever but anyway she she was voted on
by political people that are opponents
of hers of course she pissed all of them
off and of course they're like well we
don't like you and this is a really easy
way for us to get rid of you she's
arguing though that that was her
fighting show she was just showing is
that this is what Islam is all about
this is what this group is about and now
she's paying the price well I think
they're thinking hey you know what this
broad could win this thing that's what I
think is really going on yeah it just so
happens that her numbers are going way
up yeah right now as a result of this
and they don't understand it's like
they're giving her a gift yeah like
listen she is an abrasive person Mar Le
Pen I think she's got a brass pair and
again I don't agree with everything she
does but when she sometimes I H when she
walked in with the was it the uh was it
the Ambassador the Iranian Ambassador
where she walked in and wanted to wear a
head scarf she just walked in like it
wasn't even a second thought she's like
no I'm not wearing that yeah like you we
no you we you go home by I have an
incredible amount of respect for that I
don't have to agree with her about
everything but someone who can be I'm
not saying she's an aborn person at all
I'm saying someone let's say you were to
take someone who's like the worst racist
in the world it doesn't mean that they
can't be right about something and I'm
not saying that Marie Le Pen is the
worst racist in the world I'm saying
even if you don't agree with everything
she has to say she's not wrong about
everything and in this instance this is
a there are lines in the for freedom of
speech and for the left to constantly
line up against it you need to see
what's happening in Europe and here's
what's so important about that people
say well that wouldn't happen in the
States but Bernie Sanders wants us to be
like Europe Nancy Pelosi wants us to be
like Europe Hillary Clinton wants us to
be like Europe and guess what you cannot
remove from that you cannot extract from
Europe just the socialism policies you
can't extract the fiscal
authoritarianism while removing the Free
Speech authoritarianism you can't say we
want to be like Europe and talk about a
70% income taxx rate or whatever it is
or talk about what's going on in Norway
or talk about what's going on in Iceland
you cannot say that and then say but you
know we want to keep our freedom of
speech Europe as a whole it's an
ecosystem and because of the economic
authoritarianism it has to rely on
cultural authoritarianism you can't take
it you can't Buffet this thing and
that's one thing where a lot of people
who are moving along the trail like I'm
antisocial Justice Warrior but I like
Bernie Sanders socialism this is where
it leads always always you can find me
zero historical examples of it not
ending this way
and lots of people typically die too so
this is true lot people typically die
Bernie Sanders bread lines when you
think about them are actually a good
thing
no no they're not Bernie what do you
mean by the way did you see Venezuela is
down to like the last couple
bucks that was in the news of borrowed
money Bitcoin now Bernie Sanders looking
at going why don't you just bake up some
more
[Laughter]
ride
speaking of Things I Hate About The
Press let's move along uh an alternative
response to Trump's address to Congress
on Tuesday this is making the rounds
it's very popular because of Vox uh it
came from uh Latino woman in Spanish
talking about immigrants talking about
Donald Trump's racist policy against
Mexicans and uh no by the way we're not
talking about uh the uh statement the
brilliant statement that Conan O'Brien
made in broadcasting from
Mexico
look at
that I don't know what the point was and
the worst part that doesn't show the
whole story by the way they didn't show
you what happened after the show uh when
he was going back to his hotel what
happened between the show and the
[Music]
hotel we usually have better Photoshop
jobs than that I say even even for us I
need to formally apologize jez uh no it
was dreamer and activist her name is ASD
Silva gave a response in Spanish on
telmundo and Univision two things I
hate as a dreamer uh she wrote this and
they the LEF is telling us as a bold
message for Latinos she wrote in this
country there is no space for
discrimination racial profiling or
persecution but sadly this is what the
Trump Administration has brought forth
for Latino and
immigrants um do you does anyone want to
take a take a crack as to why this is
false uh this is too easy right like I
feel like this is a trick question it's
not a trick question not a trick
question oh boy it's not like Common
Core math it's like what's 2 plus two
you're like four like it's 492 no
show you work yeah they're saying he's
against Latinos and immigrants let's
let's think hold on let's think for a
second doesn't seem like Donald Trump
hates immigrants because his wife is an
immigrant and he has plenty of
immigrants who are either married into
his family or immigrants who he works
with he seems to have a lot of respect
for immigrants so let's think if it's
clear that doesn't necessarily hate all
immigrants what is the problem that he
has if he's talking about building a
wall in Immigration
policy can anyone can anyone think about
it h send us your comments right now
tweet me at s
Crowder could it be that there's some
sort of a delineation
perhaps I'm going to keep doing this
until someone pipes up apparently Jared
and jald I'm GNA I'm G to take a stab
I'm take a stab risk here guess there's
a delineation between legal and illegal
immigrants there you go I know I waited
so long and I knew the answer the whole
time it's science uh it is it is
remark this is a slight of hand you see
from the left all the time and they
continue to do it and people aren't
buying it Like Donald Trump hates
immigrants here's the deal Donald Trump
came out and he made some some some
comments about Mexicans at one point
that were poorly worded they're not
setting their best they're setting
rapists and it's
like jeez okay Don and I listen I know
Donald doesn't mean to say that all
Mexicans are rapists and that's what
they tried to run with but it was poorly
worded
rather than jump on that now they're
going he hates all immigrants so they've
squandered the lead that they had
because people hold on a second he
clearly doesn't hate all immigrants he
just has a problem with what illegal
immigration hold on a second I voted for
Hillary but yeah I don't like that
either I don't like illegal immigration
either is is it me am I racist NE that
at Obama like six years ago six years
ago it is it's a fundamental delineation
and this is why just throw it out just
th it's really easy to end this debate
when this happen it's really you don't
need to get into unless you accept that
there's a delineation between illegal
and legal immigrants don't even engage
in the discussion when someone say well
Donald Trump hates immigrants or when
they say well building a wall is
anti-immigrant just say no illegal
immigrant people aren't illegal okay you
prefer the word
criminal criminal immigrant yes that
could work that's what they say right
they're like people are not illegal acts
are illegal okay illegal acts committed
by a criminal well you said this last
time we were talking about about a year
ago not in Trump but we were talking
about it in general you said look we're
either a nation laws or not right one
way or the other pick yeah pick and and
while we're at it while you pick um we
found this this public service video a
children's video actually which
hopefully we'll be able to drill it into
your Noggin U exactly how to make the
delineation between legal and illegal I
hope this is
informative I'm legal and I'm illegal I
follow the law respected the process you
see I just came here illegal
to some immigration is nuanced almost
subliminal don't look at me I'm just a
criminal I work to skill trade and pay
legal taxes I just came here to sell all
the CES I came here on a work visa then
took my naturalization oath one time I
killed a
guy it seems you're confused let's play
a game you ask if it's legal then I will
explain okay
okay paying state tax legal selling
cocaine illegal buying a TV legal
stealing a TV illegal protesting the
government legal killing a guy in the
government illegal kidnapping you for
Rome illegal I'm still going to do wait
what an O to the Homemaker though lady's
work is often thought to be less
meaningful less fulfilling and less
productive than that of a hardworking
male counterpart the weaker sex earns
her keep to the daily task of food
preparation ensuring your Hub is fully
satisfied is a daunting task but how
does she do it what's a secret to
ensuring 100% satisfaction morning noon
and night the lorth c.com mugclub little
lady's favorite helper for only $99
annually $69 for students and Veterans
the mug Club is clinically proven to
enhance the aroma and flavor of all
Beverages and soups by 64% no more fat
lips for you you too can enjoy these
clinically proven results as well as
daily programming at louder with cr.com
mugclub no more fat
lips
reach the
[Music]
wizard I didn't do the Kata for this one
because I I feel like I've been
educating people on the art of far too
much uh actually very excited to have
this next guest because when I grew up
and I was starting in comedy I knew who
he was and watched him with my brother
back when my space was still a thing uh
you can follow him on Twitter Owen
Benjamin he has the podcast why didn't
they laugh good stuff and uh big fan
Owen Benjamin thank you for being on the
show sir thanks for having me I'm a fan
of yours as well oh don't say that
because then I'll get a big head and
this show will begin to suck uh I'll be
like not K Jared at that point people
say why why are you still gainfully
employed um I watched you back when you
did the fanny pack song we were just
talking about this first off let me just
there's no way to off air okay let's
just talk about what happened there's no
way to so we were preparing the shot and
Owen Benjamin was on the other side of
Skype and we're sitting there and I we
see this black thing in his teeth now
it's not super clear I have a small
Monitor and my producer is going is that
food in his teeth so for 2 minutes we
were trying to work around it we nak
Jared saying hey Owen can you change the
light back the camera a little bit
because we weren't sure if he had a
space in his teeth or it was food and
then finally we're Googling image
searches does he have that space in his
teeth and ask him Owen do you have any
food in your tee oh yeah that was
pizza yeah hey you guys are like just
for lighting can you quickly get braces
for four
years can you go get your retainer for
us and call us back in eight
months well good that's one of your best
features too your teeth so look at that
I'm glad it worked out look at that yeah
look at that very healthy how much would
he have hated us if you let him do that
though we're like we're like best
friends I know you guys back well that's
the challenge and then and then all
and then all these dudes with uh spaces
in their teeth come to my shows because
I'm like the brave one and then they
find out I don't really have
one man if he can do it all of us can
make it it's kind of like redheads and
then they get to the end of the rainbow
and they realize there's no pot of gold
for you
redheads um no so uh Owen you reached we
were I found out you were tweeting me
and uh you know I by the way do you
remember Tom VB did you ever did you
ever do stand up with him he used to
work in La a bit he was kind of doing
open mics and coming up and he was big
fan of yours and like Kyle dunan yeah
love Kyle dunan yeah I so maybe you
don't remember Tom but I remember just
that was kind of an air There Was You
Kyle dunigan um gosh I remember Tom I I
totally remember Tom yeah yeah I don't I
wonder what happened to him you remember
those friends you're like oh man I
wonder what happened to him he was a
funny guy and then you know most them
now that's just kind of the nature of
Comedy I'm sure Owen see you know a lot
of people think H comedians are silly
but the work ethic required I mean for
someone to reach your level of success
in this industry most of the people
you've known in your career
by this point have probably just dropped
off and you're still there that's a huge
part of it yeah it's it's almost like a
mental optical illusion that you think
everyone just keeps succeeding because
you're only really paying attention to
those people if you just start thinking
of all the funny people you've known and
how few of them get to Madison Square
Garden it's pretty hilarious this is
true now you've played the garden is
that what you're saying no I have it I'm
one of the people that have it
okay let's act like this is going
honesty is did just do a tour in England
with the Impractical Jokers though and
uh I got to do uh 10 20,000 Cedar which
was insane oh wow now that's your
favorite show right nak a I I used to I
love the first season first season was
really good I felt like it got a little
repetitive as it went on yeah but it was
I it was really funny n jar had some
disagreements on Comedy and some of the
Impractical Joker bits were some of them
were the ones I thought was fun were
funny he didn't find funny and then also
the the greatest crime against humanity
n Jared finds Jimmy Fallon funny so I
don't know how this I don't know how
this happen I think Jimmy no way what's
going on man hey I'm Jimmy Fallon
right just shut up I don't think I don't
if he's funnier I but I think his show
is more entertaining than say Kimmel I
think it's more entertaining to watch
the Kimmel Kimmel Kimmel's gotten old to
me yeah I guess I don't know I just I
did well there's also Conan is still
around too there are other programs
you're aware of this it's non-binary but
we talked about Conan okay so speaking
of non-binary sorry then we have a guest
here on Benjamin so he was tweeting back
and forth you have been going after the
Hollywood leftist Elite on TW and I just
wasn't aware of it you don't live in LA
anymore correct you just you you removed
yourself from that situation yeah cuz I
had a baby and I just um it it's just
safer here and it's closer to family and
I just you know I like it up here but uh
I always have been I did a tweet a few
years ago where I'm like I came to La a
liberal and now I'm a conservative and
none of my opinions changed right yeah
yeah it's almost like an outrage Ponzi
scheme that went to the point where like
I didn't relate
cuz I was never really into politics I
just I'm into free speech and you know
uh just stuff that makes America
great and stuff that makes my job
possible right and you know you're from
Canada I used to live in the Czech
Republic so it's like I think there's
certain people that can see the outcome
of government control to a ridiculous
degree right and it's scares you a
little bit like a comedian can be sued
in Canada yes well we had him on M in
the Republic you go into a store and and
they still don't understand the like
trying to sell things right so like I
I've always been very wary of socialism
and things like that and then on the
social front I don't you know I love
Thomas sa the uh Economist wrote yeah
black redneck white liberals one of my
favorite books and um very conservative
uh Economist and people called him
racist even though he's black from
Harlem in 1930 dir yeah and I'm like
there's something wrong here man like
you guys are like not right in the head
anymore yeah I mean Harlem back then we
always say this about Ben Carson like
he's he he's playing he's playing pro
ball for the black team he's not in the
minor Pros he's not b-league right
Harlem kind of like like uh Ben Carson
he was from Detroit single mother and
tried to stab her but she was saved by
her belt buckle this guy has the black
experience you know but for some reason
they don't apply it because of their
opinions right same with Thomas got like
massacred by Ted Kennedy and a bunch of
other quote unquote uh privileged white
liberals because you know and his
grandfather was like a sharecropper you
know it's like I just don't like I
started seeing and my parents are
professors but they were from like you
know they taught at like Jesuit colleges
and stuff so they had that like moral
background that I think a lot of
professors don't currently have and they
don't know what to make of all of it
either they're like I call them liberals
like it ends in a question mark right
yeah where it's like is that because
they don't relate anymore to the party
they don't relate that every minority is
a victim just for existing that the
Constitution doesn't matter that
censorship is is good if it like hurts
people's feelings like you know I was
doing a bit about how um a lot of the
progressives I call them indoor cats and
and I do this long bit about it and I
started realizing I could at first like
it was fine like Hollywood laughed and
then it got to the point where it's like
it became almost political and I'm like
no this is about culture right like our
culture can't become this monster of
like no one can speak and everyone's
judged based on what victim group
they're in and and so that's why I just
can't call myself a liberal and that's
what's crazy about the entertainment
industry think about it right um until
like hash Oscars so white as a general
rule comedy in the entertainment
industry is a pretty good example of a
meritocracy If You're the Best comedian
you to do better actor and then now
they're going a crap we got to give the
award to the gay black otherwise
people there's going to be a March um
and and it's it's changed and com the
thing is for me I was talking with Nick
doollo about this I think a lot of
comedians who were successful from that
generation were you know Lenny Bruce
liberal Bill Hicks liberal but free
speech Advocates so they still think in
the clubs they're like no no and stand
up it's still a Bastion of free speech
I'm going you don't live in the world
today where the people who paved the way
weren't Lenny Bruce or Bill Hicks it's
Amy Schumer and it's Sarah Silverman who
now closing the door behind them for
free speech that's why people are going
online and standup is sort of becoming
the PC Brigade if you look at people at
the top I I totally agree and it's like
I I don't think anyone can say what's
funny you know it's like oh that's not
funny it's like I'll show you a thousand
people laughing like it's not funny to
you and and and I don't think people
have the right to do that and a lot of
these PC Brigade upper Ean people used
to be free speech and now they're is
Shifting yeah and that's why I'm like
the way that a lot of them like I used
to love Sarah Silverman when she would
be very irreverent and very you know she
talk about how um you know just her
irreverent jokes and she had a bit I
remember she talked about the like
Christian children's fun like those
those sort of save African children and
she was like I was like oh my God who's
allowing these kids to get pregnant cuz
they all had like the bellies and
everyone was like oh she was cringe
shock humor and now she's mad at people
simply for voting Donald Trump claiming
its hate speech I just I can't get my
mind around it that's another thing that
got to me it's like people would rather
overthrow the government than have a
president they don't agree with like
that to me is shocking yeah you know and
I'm like you cannot like Trump but just
realize he was democratically elected
you know and you just got to go with
that and and it's just they started
talking very scary to me and that's why
I don't really I'm not going to pretend
I agree with any of those things well
have you been shunned since you've
because I know you say you've always
sort of had these views but you've
become more outspoken about them
certainly on on social media was it one
of those things for you for me this is
what happened I was always this way and
I found out pretty quickly if people
find out at all about My Views I mean I
had a a manager drop me I had an agent
drop me I had publicists who wouldn't
touch it once they saw some of the
things that I had said I said you know
what I've got to I've got to run with
this because I can't put that Genie back
in a bottle is that what happened with
you and do you feel that you've had some
friends or people who you considered
open-minded who who've shunned you since
they found out about your views
yeah for me it's uh it was being on
Sullivan and Son on TBS because it was
produced by Vince vaugh and starring
Steve Burn uh Roy Wood Jr metaed all
these people and it was so Multicultural
but not in that left vicy way right and
we got no love from like and we're the
number one show on TBS when it was on
and there was you know media didn't get
behind it they didn't talk about the
Triumph of a Korean star wait is that is
that number one outside of Tyler Perry
is it kind of like the Bibles always a
number one bestseller so they don't even
include on the list anymore or were you
beating uh Tyler Perry's uh media Go's
Buu oh that's a word no well that's the
thing we didn't have much going against
us we had the uh reruns of big bang but
okay don't get n started he hates the
Big Bang Theory don't Let's Just Jared
we'll talk about that another time the
guest doesn't have that much time and uh
and so I just uh I just saw that it was
hypocritical and I I got into comedy
because I'm not good at lying like I'm
is it's not in my nature to kind of
pretend I'm something I'm not and I I I
still don't really consider myself very
political I just can't agree with uh
this whole like uh identity politics and
limiting of free speech and all the
stuff that I have so much pride in being
American for and I just think that white
pride did I just hear white pride you
sis white male it's I love being white
when cops pull me over they just
highfive
me I know for me they just give me
dumplings which they stole off an Asian
who they shook down earlier I'm like
what are you doing this is fantastic
they give me their gun it's great yeah I
know it is that was one thing that
really upset my dad uh well you're you
said so you were you how long did you
spend uh what portion of your life in
the Czech
Republic uh I was there for a year uh
1999 oh okay I thought you now are your
parents uh from there no I was a World
War II history major and I really wanted
to study history there I thought he was
an immigrant here like oh really I
didn't know about that ow Benjamin oh no
not at all I just went there and lived
there and like just being in that
environment I I I realized that
government control is not good well
speaking of third world countries my dad
was raised in Detroit so for him he got
so pissed when Bernie Sanders said you
know that that white people can't really
know what it's like to struggle and he
was there divorced family you know his
dad was in the military so uh not a
wealthy family by any means in Detroit
proper by the way in the in the area
that people like to claim they're from
he was actually inside of 8 Mile in
Detroit proper and uh divorced family
was part of the racial integration
busing system got his ass kicked day in
and day out because he was white there
was a lot of racial tension and uh and
his his Saving Grace was hockey he was
he was a really good hockey player got
to play at U ofm that's what pulled him
out of it and so he goes yeah do I think
that maybe I've enjoyed some advantages
that other people haven't you can say
attribute it to being white maybe but I
also think that other people have had
privileges that I haven't had being
being raised to a divorced family in
inner city Detroit uh in a lower middle
class household it's called life and he
got so mad about that but it seems that
even people his age when he talks with
his friends who are black they feel the
same way it's like welcome to the world
population Earth plus you now once you
understand it yeah my mother's father
was a a lead Miner with seven fingers
and she was one of the first people to
go to college from her town you know
it's like and that's why I love Thomas
sa you'd love love this book Black
redneck I've read it yeah oh yeah where
it's about how life just isn't fair
sometimes and it's more about culture
than it is uh race in fact race is
almost no Factor like you know Nigerian
Americans make more than Caucasian
Americans it's about a certain type of
culture that doesn't value education
promotes violence promote you know it's
also because I sent their prince all
that money what's that I said it's also
because I sent their prince all that
money so there's some trickled point he
tricked me too yeah I know remember that
when that was new and like we all had
email like oh my gosh someone sent me an
email and you're like oh wow this is
kind of like a pen pal there's that no
one wants to admit it but when it first
started all of us probably almost fell
for at least one of them dude I almost
fell for it like a month
ago yeah are you forward in that picture
like have you seen this dog on steroids
you're like no that's clearly a
Photoshop I know I remember I remember
it with my space you know what's funny
back then um I got in I remember a lot
of comedians got really mad uh I I had
been doing standup for 6 months but I
was doing standup I did my first open
mic within three months I was doing an
hour now not not a good hour what
happened was someone asked me to co-host
a talent show at a university with them
in Montreal or a college sorry and I
said okay and I did well enough there
that the guy who booked the colleges
said hey how come I never heard you you
you headline around here and I said yes
and he said okay come back and do 40
minutes in a month and then when I got
that I booked about four or five
different colleges within that week cuz
I said well I'm doing Dawson College
they having me do 45 minutes and I play
them off one another so I got a lot of
experience really quickly I mean think
about you know doing five one hour shows
in the span of two weeks most people
starting out don't get that kind of
experience for years because you're
scraping together five minute Clips so
this is before Myspace I put my my my
stuff up on MySpace and a talent scout
had no idea who I was said hey do you
want to audition for the just for laughs
and I did and I got in and I remember
comedians being so pissed and again I
remember just as a conservative thinking
like well isn't this good doesn't this
mean that you can get in next year it
doesn't matter how long you've been
doing it and and instead they were mad
yeah it's like this zero some game
mentality that like it's almost like the
race to the bottom type thing where it's
it's it's you you almost latch on to the
least talented people because it makes
you feel better about yourself when like
I always like friends that were very
successful and did well because I fed
off that energy yeah and I just I just
don't relate to the to that that quote
unquote Progressive it's not Progressive
it is regressive yeah and it's gotten to
a point where it it it just doesn't make
sense anymore and that will probably
affect my career even just leaving
affects your career just just being like
I have a family I want to raise my
family near my family uh but I don't
really care you know I make money on the
road I got a book I'm writing a book I
do podcast it's all about family well
tell tell let us know when your book
comes out and speaking of you know
having people who Elevate you I need to
reevaluate why I let not gay Jared hang
around in this show do something with
your life good Lord not gay Jared um
it's true it really is true it's it's
and there's this sort of there was at
one point and I felt this way I don't
know if you felt this way it was hard
for you leaving Los Angeles and I think
it's a smart decision raising a family
getting out of the intolerance but a big
part of stand-up comedians right uh
their identity is in standup and so
there's like this hierarchy like man if
you don't do if you're not on the road
grinding out with clubs whereas most of
them would rather be Bill Burr doing
giant theaters you know not having to do
that or have a career like you have um
where we have a sustainable audience but
there's this idea that unless you're
sticking with like this is the only pure
form of entertainment and and I think
that's changing a lot like you said you
can do podcasts you can do things online
where you don't have Club Bookers or
show Bookers with standup it has become
so vanilla to me when I tune into a
comedy showcase on television I can
almost if there's going to be a
political joke I can tell you exactly
what it's going to be and I can tell you
which subjects they'll touch on to be
politically incorrect while avoiding the
real subjects are not allowed to talk
about is it just me when I watch those
no you're 100% and and uh conservatives
seem to understand uh uh business better
when it comes to that's a disadvantage
in business anytime you're not going for
funnyest possible that means there is a
Market opening up because you're not
trying to be funny or trying to appease
some Overlord you know right so that's
why I don't mind uh appealing to the
audience that I want to appeal to and
then just finding the shows that uh you
know I can get it's it actually pays
better sometimes yeah it does once you
free yourself from the ego of like yeah
but if I leave La I don't have all the
cool kids you know what I mean there is
that part I think for a lot of people
that's really hard to do um just to get
out of it it's like the mob I know but
the the weird thing is though is they're
still like the good ones are still my
boys like right and and you you tell Who
Your Friends Are by that where it
doesn't really matter how you feel about
put like okay here's a perfect example
uh your ability of debate like I don't
want to blow up your head but my dad
teaches debate like he's a rhetoric
Professor okay and it's like you're just
crushing like I I listen to you with
Michael Ian Black and I'm like any
moderator knows he like Stephen won like
there isn't even a debate and I'm like I
always thought the left was the one that
had like science and logic and it's
becoming absolutely not bad at all no
and and with Michael in Black I will say
it got heated more heated than I would
like uh and we'll have him back on the
show but um you know I don't I really
honestly if you if you want to talk
about debate look to someone like Ben
Shapiro he's amazingly skilled I I will
say this for I genuinely not g Jared
knows this when we have someone on who's
who I disagree with I do research to see
what their views are and I genuinely try
and conduct a debate first off the rule
is NJ is not allowed to jump in at all
no one else it's not fair to Doggy pile
that's my rule he can't bring up
something for me and research it you
know and be my never-ending assistant it
just is me and that person and I
genuinely am trying to get to the truth
because if I'm wrong I want to know it
and um if you listen to some of our
debates there's been some common ground
that could be found but not with like
Christopher Titus you know where was the
gun debate and he's like why don't you
care about dead kids or Michael Black
going isn't one rape too many one rape
is rape culture like that's not the same
thing it's the worst possible Straw Men
you can possibly do where it's like
that's why I'm having a hard time with
with that side because it's like it's
almost like they're not trying to learn
they're trying to win right and and I I
I want to go into a debate where if
someone makes a great point it's like oh
wow thank you for clearing that up right
like I was making a horrible mistake yes
yeah I was wrong you're correct I might
be a homosexual thank you for making me
aware of this yeah like I didn't know
that those stats were the stats like I
thought one in five women really were
raped on College it's like really or oh
perfect one perfect one is a wage Gap
yeah like I really thought that wage Gap
and just like a bunch of people thought
that and then when you actually break it
down if there is no wage Gap that isn't
factoring in having children and like
child rearing and like that's so in
career yeah here's the thing and then we
we do have to go I'll have to bring you
back but here's something that that for
me that's that's the start of the issue
right I found out okay wage Gap is a
myth so for me that's where it starts me
on the trail going but I've heard Barack
Obama our sitting president at the time
Trot this out um does he not have access
to Google or is heying ex that's that's
what got me paranoid yeah you know I'm
like do they do they knowingly do this
because I've made him like my motto is I
might be wrong but I'm not lying right
yeah you know and I'm like if he knew it
and did that that's such divisive evil
stuff and and it's one thing if you
don't know but it's like you know you
see Thomas sa in 1984 hashing out the
these yeah these issues and it's like
how does he not know that that's not
real it's kind of like the gun thing not
involving suicides where it's like you
know that like you're inflating this
number on like when someone says like x
amount of hom uh gun deaths a year and
they don't include the fact that it's
half suicides right that's
intellectually dishonest right yeah and
and then they compare they compare gun
crime rates across countries and not
crime rates and it's like well listen
obviously if guns are more accessible in
a country that has allowed Firearms
they're going to be using to carry out
more crimes but that doesn't mean that
the crime rate is worse or the homicide
rate is worse especially when you
eliminate gang violence because listen
we have different cultures in the United
States it's not the same as Iceland that
has half the population of Rhode Island
and is entirely homogeneous you can't
really compare them despite what Bernie
Sanders says anyways I can go on all day
uh Owen Benjamin Owen Benjamin on
Twitter where's the best what's the best
stuff for people to find on you uh my
website is hugepianist
touring schedule is and I'm uh in
Vancouver next week and I'm all over the
place so hit that up because I'm tall
and I play piano so make sure you spell
it right though or else it's a weird
yeah otherwise it takes you to a site
and that is not Owen Benjamin um huge
pianist
docomo Benjamin thank you so much
brother we'll have you back and we have
to be back after this stay tuned nice to
having
[Music]
me
whether preparing supper or tidying up
the mess afterward the Homemaker finds
meaning and purpose in her kitchen
almost exclusively but where does she
find all that energy how do her dainty
fingers hold up against such grueling
manual labor yes that's right the L with
Crow of mug Club scientifically proven
to make even the most mundane and
trivial of tasks 78% more enjoyable
hubby has no tolerance for frowny faces
for only $99 annually $69 for students
veterans or active military you too can
toil with a smile L with.com mugclub
join now for daily L with crer content
and to avoid a fat lip for
you always great to bring back the
family values with those old classic
commercials Classics take them out from
the Vault right next to Walt Disney's
anti-semitic corpse uh how often do you
hear us do uh live reads well really
it's about once a week right now and
thank you so much for those who've
joined the mug Club who watch The Daily
Show that's obviously the most important
thing we can't thank you enough but we
do have a promo going on right now
here's one thing we don't ever want to
be in the business of selling you
anything that you do not want uh this is
something we're pretty excited about we
ran the special a while ago it was
prepare with CR now it's prepare with
crowd.com let me be the first to say I'm
not a doomsday theorist I'm not a
prepper I don't think uh everything's
going to hell in a hand basket but I did
live through the Montreal ice storms
where many people died where we were out
of power we had no access to food or
water for over a week my brother was in
Los Angeles for the riot so I do think
that it pays to be prepared and right
now if you go to prepare withth crow.com
you get a 30-day emergency food supply
kit $99 shipped free that's breakfast
lunch and dinner for four whole weeks
$99 shipped free you you can't really
build this Supply kit that inexpensively
certainly not this diverse and I don't
know about you but I I I buy a couple of
kits I I put them in our cupboard and I
leave them there so I have peace of mind
that's really what it comes down to in
case it any kind of a natural disaster
occurs so that's prepare withth crow.com
and they're great Partners great
supporters to the show uh if you feel
like it's a product that you need that
you could use I think everyone should be
prepared great do it or you can call 888
41151 53 prepare withthomas
$99 shipped free and uh limited supplies
we did it for a while back and it ended
within the month because we sold out so
uh thank you so much for your support
we'll be back after this Jordan
Peterson
[Music]
that's the ancient art of kada I've been
teaching you about that this week
because um this is a multicultural show
uh so you do
this and then proceed to get your ass
kicked our guest is at Jordan B Peterson
uh Dr Peterson uh he has been in the
program four and uh I mean so many
accolades we could toss here you've just
your your your your I guess the public
awareness has gone up like a rocket ship
since we last had you on uh Dr Peterson
what's that like for you you're you're
now you're
notorious well it's busy most I mean it
it's interesting I'm not exactly sure
what to make of it one one one thing
that has happened though is that I now
get up at 5:00 in the morning and start
working because in order to keep up with
this at the moment I that was pretty
much what I had to do um it's I'm a
curious person and while people have
probably already figured that out yes I
didn't mean that I'm curious in The
Eccentric way I mean that I'm curious
about things and so I'm very curious
about this it's it's
um it it certainly wasn't something I
expected although I have to tell you
that I've been amazed for decades that
I've been allowed to teach what I do
teach at the University and that no
one's ever noticed and stopped me from
doing it so the fact that attention has
been brought to it in some sense I
suppose doesn't come as a surprise well
I think but I'm happy I'm happy about
the opportunities that it's bringing me
and and I'm I do like to teach people
and so the fact that now I can make a
video and and reliably attract 50,000
viewers is great as far as I'm concerned
it's like why not I'm I'm hoping that I
can teach people about psychology and
now I can so hooray and it's it's
remarkable that you know in the age of
sort of the Kardashians and the reality
stars sort of generation as we as we
call it you skyrocketed to to public
awareness really through through telling
the truth which has sort of become the
counterculture and that's what I find so
interesting about about your situation
it's one of those things where you said
something that shouldn't have been
offensive and it caught on like wildfire
simply because it was truthful um and of
course you that's come with a lot of
fans and I'm sure it's come with a lot
of headaches now one thing we went to
Twitter earlier today asking okay what
do you want us to most discuss with Dr
Peterson and surprisingly enough even
from a lot of atheists they said you
know I want to hear his views on on
faith uh I know you're going to be doing
a a series will it be an online series
on uh yeah yeah I plan well I plan to do
it the the plan at the moment is to rent
a theater on the University of Toronto
campus and I'd like to do a lecture
every week for as long as it takes it
might be a number of years but the first
plan is for 25 weeks I've wanted to walk
my way through the Bible from a
psychological perspective for I've been
thinking about it for a decade I I
talked to a TV producer producer here
who I've worked with for a very long
time who was interested in that and Mel
Gibson yes Mel exactly yeah yeah yeah
thank you very much for that so just
figured we'd end your career right now
just Dead on
Arrival yeah so I mean i' i' I've spent
a lot of time on many of the ancient
stories in the Bible trying to
understand what they mean from a
psychological perspective and this would
certainly provide me with the necessity
for doing that my life is structured so
and I think this is true for many people
so that unless I have a deadline in the
absolute necessity for doing something
the probability that it will fall off my
list of priorities is very high so sure
now I have I know that if I make this
series then I can get tens of thousands
of people I know that there are tens of
thousands of people who would
be uh engaging with it online and just
seems foolish not to do it so yeah
that's the plan well I F I I do have a
lot of respect for you in this area
because obviously with you know sort of
fighting social justice Warriors as
they're called has become some has
become has become somewhat I don't know
if I had a stroke today or what's going
on it's become somewhat popular now and
it's kind of accepted because they're so
absurd right people they they love to
make them a whipping post and
appropriately so by the way I think it's
a perfect whipping post people who are
social justice Warriors however a lot of
these people who are coming along this
sort of political cultural Trail I've
noticed were previously part of this
this sort of leftist atheist Coalition
so it's still immensely unpopular uh to
be someone uh whose Faith really is is a
big part of their of their what defines
them as a human and you were on Sam
Harris's podcast and that was one that
really sort of went back and forth and I
I was surprised as to how roundabout he
went with you a little bit for someone
who's usually very very clear um in his
thought thoughtful approach what was the
reaction to that and did you get have
you had more atheists upset saying well
I used to respect you until I found out
you believe in the Flying Spaghetti
Monster which we all get or or have you
found more of them uh interested in what
you have to say and wanting to learn
about it well I would say certainly that
one of the consequences of appearing on
Sam's show was that more people were
attracted to watch my videos and so I
have had responses from people that are
of the sort that you described who said
well I I am pleased with Dr Peterson's
political stance but when he starts
talking about the intersection between
religion and psychology then I just tune
out it's but that that's fine with me I
actually don't it doesn't it isn't
I'm not trying to convince people right
it's up to people to think whatever they
want and and if they don't find what I'm
saying convincing or interesting then
that's perfectly fine um I'm also not
claiming that what I'm saying is correct
because what I'm trying to talk about is
insanely complicated which is partly why
I wanted to talk to Sam Harris about it
I mean the thing about Harris is that he
he has has concentrated on many of the
same problems that that have bothered me
and has actually come to similar
conclusions but for very different
reasons and right and I thought we could
have an interesting conversation about
that because he does believe that people
have a primary moral obligation to speak
the truth and that he also believes that
one of the primary moral obligations
that characterize human
human human beings let's say is that
they should try to work to mitigate
unnecessary suffering which is also
something that I agree with but sure
think the problem with his approach is
that it is I don't think that what he's
promoting is grounded deeply enough to
to to have the kind of power that's
necessary for to make
it manifest itself properly yeah and I
also think that that Harris and Dawkins
it's quite funny because they they just
talked to each other very recently um
Harris put Dawkins on the spot by
suggest suggesting that there may have
been evolutionary reasons for the
selection of religious idation and I
actually happen to believe that I think
and I think that both Harris and Dawkins
and this is mostly at Dawkins feet has
never taken the uh the the fact of the
prevalence of religious thinking with
the sort of seriousness that an
evolutionary biologist should that's
interesting because religious thinking
is a human Universal sure and not only
that it's how we thought it's how all of
us thought all the time roughly speaking
before the scientific method was
invented and so for the vast majority of
our evolutionary history the essential
way that we oriented oursel in the world
was indistinguishable from the religious
and it worked right so because here we
are after all and there's and we're all
fascinated most psychologists with sort
of these these evolutionary you know
psychological coping mechanisms and so I
I would imagine that an atheist might
sort of toss that out maybe it's a smoke
screen that well it's a coping mechanism
for what we don't understand in the
physical world sure well that's what
Freud said roughly speaking right but
it's interesting that that like you said
the sort of the most prominent atheist
thinkers or certainly speakers I don't
know if we'd call them philosophers I
don't know the proper terminology
necessarily it's interesting that they
really don't touch upon that a whole lot
I mean I've read Dawkins I've listened
to Harris quite a bit and it surprises
people often being a Christian um and I
do think that you're part of I would I
would say sort of a new wave where I
think that a big reason for this
culturally is there was Sam Harris there
was Richard Dawkins and then there were
people out there who would just say
crazy outlandish things on behalf of
Christianity and I don't know if that's
because atheists sort of kept people
like you from the podium or it's just
that the craziest Christians sometimes
grabbed the podium but this thoughtful
professorial approach which really was
was the norm in Christianity if you go
back to you know CS Lewis or Chesterton
right this is this is not a new way of
thinking but it certainly has been
absent for the last several decades and
it seems like you're part of a new way
who might Usher in um a new era of
critical thinking for Christians to
discuss with atheists alike do you do
you feel like you're a part of that well
that would be that would be lovely I
would say because it's certainly
something that I'm interested in I mean
um I think that there's a very profound
discussion that has to be had between
evolutionary biologists and
psychologists and people with with with
uh well with people of of of deep and
profound religious Faith because I think
the evidence that there are elements of
religious phenomenology that are rooted
in our biology is absolutely
overwhelming so for example you can
reliably induce experiences that people
characterize as religious with
hallucinogens like psilocybin right and
it's extraordinarily well documented
evidence of that particularly in recent
years coming from John's Hopkins a very
reliable and conservative medical a hate
group to hear Jess herps transgender M
of New Hope uh refer to it John Hopkins
a hate group not real doctors what we
were told only hate group yeah but but
the the the researchers there have shown
that people who have a who who are given
psilocybin for example a a a very large
majority of them uh report
extraordinarily powerful mystical
experiences that they regard as among
the most important of their life and not
only that that those experiences have a
profound and lasting impact on their
personality now I'm not necessarily
certain that more traditional religious
people are going to be very thrilled
with the idea that some of this some of
this kind of at least the mystical end
of this experience can be induced with
psychedelic drugs for examp can be
induced with what not gager does at a
night club on a Friday night they're not
going to be thrilled right right but but
the anthropological evidence is clear
you know that people have been inducing
these sorts of
experiences um and investigating the
Technologies to do so for tens of
thousands of years and perhaps for
longer than that so it's not something
that can be ignored it's something
terrifying to be sure right because it's
terrifying the idea that a that a
spiritual experience can genuinely be
induced or perhaps not genuinely
depending on how you look at it but can
be induced reliably with a chemical is
is
certainly it's it's you're it could give
Credence to all of those druggies who
like man just drop acid that's how you
reach the higher level and then a cult
starts and lay aedy has a reality show
let me ask you this you're going to be
talking about this in your class going
through the Bible stories an atheist
here on Twitter I don't have it up in
front of me specifically asked said your
views on on these were were fascinating
and he really like listening to you
discuss these subjects so if you're
going to go through these stories for
example I don't know if you go through
Daniel in the Lion's Den through you
know the New Testament I don't know if
you go through Genesis I don't know
exactly what it is um I would I'll be
interested to see when this this course
takes place do you look at most of them
literally do you look at most of them
metaphorically and or do you not touch
that at all you just look at it from a
modern psychological perspective no
that's a really good question well look
I W when I was a when I was a kid when I
was first in University I had the
opportunity to go out to the Edmonton
Maximum Security Prison a couple of
times with this very eccentric
psychologist who taught a course on
creativity at the University of Alberta
and uh well one moment what who could
possibly be sentenced to a Maximum
Security Prison in Edmonton they what
did they do wrong they they collected
them from many places across Canada and
and there were plenty of guys in there
that you would not want to meet in a
dark alley or even in a well-lit space
if you were surrounded by policemen
right okay so yeah yeah so anyways one
of the things that he said in his class
was that um fiction tells you the truth
by by
lying okay so I well so let's let's just
think about that for a minute so you
think about think about an author like
totoy or dovi great authors or
Shakespeare for that matter and they
they invent fictional characters and
obviously you can't take a fictional
story literally right okay but that
doesn't mean that there isn't truth in
fictional stories in fact sure good
fictional story imagine that you it
takes you 6 hours to read a powerful
piece of fiction and then compare what
you've learned about the world from that
to just living your normal life for 6
hours right the what's happened what the
novelist is doing is distilling what's
essential from normal life and
presenting it in a condensed
manner okay so imagine imagine something
like this this is obviously a metaphor
to some degree so imagine that a
literary genius watches hundred people
and then distills what he is learning
learn from watching those 100 people
into one character in a way that you can
in a manner you can digest in six hours
so it's like it's condensed and
distilled wisdom right okay now imagine
that you you have a hundred authors like
that and you take all of their books and
you distill those books into 10 books
okay well then you have the Bible W I
see what you did there you brought a
full circle and I do think it's
important to delineate um that there are
some I mean Jesus spoke Parables for
example by definition that is fiction um
you know you can compare it to Modern
ASA Fable but there is a case to be made
I certainly believe this for Jesus
Christ as a historical figure and I
would not consider the New Testament
fiction and that's one issue where it's
very hard to discuss with atheists you
know oh Flying Spaghetti Monster but um
I came to this I was raised in a
Christian household but at a certain
point people say were you born a
Christian no one is born a Christian at
some point everyone has to decide for
themselves period um reading from you
know reading uh you know tacitus
Josephus just martyr uh looking you know
tulian all of these arguments you know
obviously the empty tomb that's an
argument that is is kind of one that has
to be accounted for um I looked at it
from a logical perspective and said okay
what are the odds of this occurring this
is the historical evidence we have for
Christ as a historical figure and then I
will tell you as uh someone who likes to
think of themselves as logical what's
the gamble on this being an act of
chance um and so I think it is important
for people and I think a lot of atheists
don't get this there are some things
that are literal there are some areas
where it's a historical document and as
you're saying sometimes this is meant to
be taken um as a morality tale yeah yeah
look look I mean that the Bible is an
extraordinarily complicated document and
and it is a strange mix of of history
and mythology and and separating one
from the other is no straightforward
thing and you probably hit on the most
crucial issue there with regards to the
the let's call it the empirical reality
of the resurrection of Christ now the
first thing I have to say about that is
that I do not understand it well enough
to have a proper opinion about it and
what I mean by a proper opinion is that
I don't understand it now one of the
things that's very interesting about the
story of Christ is that it is heavily
mythologized and on multiple levels so
for example there's there's a cosmology
that's associated with Christ so Christ
is the son I mean the literal son in the
cosmology and there's 12 disciples
because each of the disciples represents
an astrological house and so the thing
that's so interesting about the story of
Christ is that it can be retold at
multiple levels of analysis and has been
and and those have all been integrated
into something that all says the same
thing now that leaves open the um the
issue of the relationship between the
historical reality and the archetype and
and the mythology for example it's quite
obvious that many of the elements of
Christ's life the way that it's
presented in the New Testament
have uh remarkable and substantive
parallels with the description of the
Egyptian god Horus right who is also a
kind of a savior God and and who was
also represented quite frequently as an
infant sitting on the lap of Isis his
mother in the same way that Christ is
represented sitting on the lap of Mary
yeah so there are these historical
parallels and they're deep and profound
and one way of reading them is that
that's just evidence that the entire
story is is is a VAR variation of of of
a myth right that's what I was taught by
Helen Holt in my mythology course in in
uh at University well not University
actually College Champlain College and I
remember asking you're saying okay well
hold on a second um how many of them
were a human sacrifice rose from the
dead and made the claim that they are
the only way to Salvation she said well
that's different I said okay now how
many historical accounts for them saw
political figures and very powerful
historical figures arguing Tales of
corrupt well actually the uh the
disciples stole his body from the tomb I
mean there are historical accounts of
this for me when I looked I'm going why
are they arguing this if see this
historical accounts they should just
Trot out Christ's body but they felt the
need because there was enough at least
public pressure if not evidence people
believed in this idea of an empty tomb
they were arguing from that premise
saying no no no this is why there's an
empty tomb and that to me was so
compelling um for the historical case
because the easiest thing would be to
say there is no empty tomb it's it's
it's but
right right that's that's personal
opinion but you're you're the scholar
the the other the
other the the issue for me in
relationship to that is twofold the
first thing is is that that's a problem
that I'm actively working on trying to
understand and I hope to do a lot more
of that over the next three or four
years because it's an extraordinarily
deep problem but um I would also say
that I've understood it in large part in
a manner that was offered to me by by by
my understanding of Carl Yung and so
Yung said so imagine I made I made a
case that you can think about the Bible
as a form of extraordinarily distilled
fiction and fiction in the best sense in
that in that fiction is a kind of
abstraction from reality like
mathematics is a kind of abstraction
from reality and you might say well our
numbers real and one answer to that is
no and the other answer is yeah they're
more real than anything else
and you can make very strong case for
both of those viewpoints because they're
not real the same way like a cup is real
but they're real in the way that allows
you to make like atom bombs I love I
love by the way that a doctor has a Solo
Cup solo you'd expect a mug and a very
distinguished pen it's the thing you
used to play beer pong I have my louder
with Crowder mug at home and use it
frequently well thank you very much I'm
glad that you do it enhances the aroma
and flavor of of beverages by
scientifically noted uh 24% so we're
very proud of of that oh that's that's
impressive yes yes I figured a doctor
that would impress you man we could talk
about this forever so but sorry we only
have a few minutes so I'll let you have
the floor okay well so I'll just I'll
just say one final thing and and this is
part of the mystery for me so just as
you can think of the Bible as a
distillation of fiction although that's
not all it is right you can think of the
idea of the Savior or the Redeemer or
the idea of Christ as a distillation of
what's what could be the best of
humanity and that sort of refle Ed in
the idea of the king of kings mhm so
imagine this imagine this is what's
happened over the course of history
again it's a metaphor but it's roughly
speaking it's it's it'll do to to
approach the topic so imagine that you
took a 100 people and you derived the
best elements from them and you
distilled those into 10
people those would be admirable Heroes
right and you could think of them as a
kind of aristocracy
sure and then imagine that you took 10
admirable Heroes and distilled them into
a
king and then you took 10 Kings and you
distilled that into a meta
King right that would be
Christ and that that's that's exactly
what happened is and this is speaking
strictly from a conceptual perspective
right I'm trying to understand the kind
of abstraction you could say that what's
happened across history is that Humanity
has attempted to produce the vision a
vision of the perfect man and the
perfect man would be everything
admirable about a human being distilled
into a single
entity now you can see that playing out
in the story of the Christian passion
because what you have what what the the
central element let let let's look at it
this way human beings have to bear a
cross well what's the cross the cross is
the burden of being alive and the
knowledge of their own mortality and and
fragility and you can either bear that
honorably or dishonorably and if you
bear it honorably then you do it by
telling the truth and living a
forthright life and aiming at the best
and those are all things that are
characteristic of the Christ that we
know from the from the from the gospels
but then to make that a truly archetypal
story you have to magnify it to to its
ultimate degree and so that's also
what's happened in the Christian story
because you have the perfect man who who
innocent of all things so that's sinless
who is betrayed by his friends which is
the worst thing that can happen to you
socially and who's then subject to
torture and death reserved for a
criminal right so it's the most unjust
possible sequence of things happening to
the best possible person right that's
what makes it archetypal you can't tell
a more meaningful story than that right
it's a limit the worst thing happens to
the best person it's a limit right you
can't go beyond it well and so that's
what that story portrays so there's a
there's a deep there's a deep reality to
it again I'm speaking purely
conceptually now but what Carl Jung
pointed out and I really like this idea
is that so imagine that that idea is an
archetypal concept it's it's the ideal
to which you should
Aspire and then it's formulated as as a
implementable ideal now that's what you
manifest if you're a follower of Christ
say in the truest sense or maybe if
you're a follower of the
Buddha now then you could imagine that
across history there are people who more
or less embody that
archetype and the people who embody it
to virtually no degree are are
uninteresting or reprehensible they're
just Scoundrels yes or
feminists but then now and then someone
comes along who's who really partially
embodies that archetype who really is a
manifestation of something approaching
the ideal and then now and then someone
comes along who really closely matches
that ideal well Steven Seagal claims
that he's the Dal Lama incarnate so
there's that so maybe I didn't know that
yeah well it's Stephen Seagal he's a
so it is interesting it is
interesting he does CL it's a hell of a
thing to call someone who's The
Reincarnation of the deli Lama yes it
would be if that were the case u i i
could talk about this all day and maybe
we'll do an extended uh version we do
have we do have uh other topics to get
to and of course we have several guests
today um I do find all that interesting
conceptually and then uh you know for me
when it comes down to you know people
aren't willing to live their life or end
their life for merely a concept so again
the historical context actually Gerald
it would be interesting if we we uh had
him here for the interview he had to go
to the restroom um when you look at
people who were persecuting Christians
and then willing to die for something in
that Lifetime with that that's that's a
rarity and that is something that again
needs to be accounted for when you can
look at it historically and say okay
these people were willing to die for
someone they new that's different from a
concept and that's a whole other layer
that we can get into um which which
again there are several different views
that you know if you're talking about a
tree branch with with Christianity I
mean that's one thing too it's really
the reason I don't engage in these
conversations as much with militant
atheists is well Christians and you and
I understand that the Christian umbrella
is is far different from I guess
atheists in the sense that you can okay
Christian you have Catholic you have
Catholic you have Protestant then you
have Protestant you have fiveo
different variables there that someone
who doesn't believe in the Christian
faith at all won't necessarily
understand um or really be able to have
a productive conversation about it and I
think uh this is one where hopefully
it's been Illuminating for people uh and
we can bring you back on to talk about
it more I this is something that can
occur for it would be nice to continue
to develop that because I would like to
talk more about the the relationship
between Christ as a historical figure
say as a literal figure and the
mythological representations it's it's
it's very interesting it's something
that Carl y spent an awful lot of time
talking about as well and and his work
on that is profound Beyond virtually
Beyond Comprehension contrary to Freud
who just wanted to screw his mother uh
Dr Peterson where is the best place for
people to find you and your
self-authoring program which I recommend
to everybody well they can find the
self-authoring program at
selfauthoring.com
that'll help them write about write
their autobiography and write a plan for
the future which is a very useful thing
to do and I have a website
jordanbpeterson.com and lots of videos
at jordanpeterson videos on YouTube
there's about 600 hours of videos there
for people who would like to watch 600
hours of videos yes exactly absolutely I
highly recommend it who needs a college
degree at this point when you can watch
600 hours of Dr Jordan Peterson Mr
Peterson Dr Peterson I apologize damn
force of habit thank you so much we must
go we'll have you back again soon sir
thanks very good to see
you what
again J what
[Music]
again
H sweet Mary and
Joseph proin Solomon get to The Fallout
Shelter
I always knew those ragheads would make
it to our shore Sullivan sir yes sir
thank the Lord above we prepared with
prepare with.com $99 ship free for a
30-day emergency food supply kit sir yes
sir everything you need reasonably
priced we have full meals free dried
fruit soup and pudding sy just add heat
and water that's right private just add
heat and
water where's all the water private
[Applause]
Sullivan do you mean to tell me that we
forent the most basic human necessity in
exchange for caffeinated sugary show to
pop I thought we need our energy sir
like the
terrorists oh
no prepare with crow.com or call 888 411
5153 30-day food supply kit $99 shipped
free
they have
[Music]
pudding
that's underwater cata for those who
weren't aware I love how we're doing the
underwater dance and Edward the sound
guys in the
background just go my jam you don't hold
your headphones underwater Edward the
sound
guy is no concept of physics or
hydrogen or
imagination uh thank you so much for our
wonderful guest own Benjamin and Jordan
B Peterson thank you g Morgan Jr for
being in absolutely sir this week pleas
G Morgan Jr hopefully you'll get a
better Twitter handle at some sometime
soon nope probably
not it's like a defiant child indeed
hopefully you'll finish your BR Sprouts
nope oh I can see we're going to
discipline
you ah man you know what it's one of
those things we got we went in some deep
conversation here tonight and sometimes
that works and sometimes people get
upset by it sometimes people really like
it so hopefully if you're listening in
your car of course you can subscribe on
iTunes SoundCloud audio if you don't
want to watch the uh the video while
you're on the go uh I know it's not
audio downloadable The Daily Show for
mug club members uh lot of.com crtv
members that's going to be there soon by
the way in the app so you'll be able to
watch the video or you'll be able to
download the audio version to take with
you and we have a lot of requests for
that so there is going to be a whole
reformatting of of the app and the site
just so you know so the reason it hasn't
been trotted out earlier is because
we're going to do it all at once so Hang
on Sloopy Hang on Sloopy hang on just
hang on it gets better than you know um
I tell you what doesn't get better the
state of CNN that is only going to get
worse we were talking about this earlier
in the show um and it's interesting that
you know Jordan Peterson and I can have
a discussion where even we even Branch
out sort of on on the discussion of of
of of Christianity somewhat I don't know
how much we disagree or agree because we
were talking about it more conceptually
but um it's interesting that we can have
I guarantee you if you to line up Jordan
Peterson me and Owen Benjamin in a room
and actually go through what our exact
views are that we all would have very
seriously differing opinions on certain
subjects I actually think that would
probably happen in this room yeah quite
a bit uh even though we're all
right-wing or more conservative but um I
don't think it happens at places like
CNN I think that with this stuff when
everyone's just when you see someone
who's being praised we talked about if
you just cycle through these stories
when you see how no one at CNN is like
you know we really should be covering
more of the story with Europe and Marie
Le Pen who's having her speech silenced
and no one goes yeah we should when
everyone's saying you know it's really
Brave this Latino woman yeah Donald
Trump hates immigrants and no one is
there saying maybe it's illegal
immigrants yeah um there really is
something dangerous we've talked about
this getting into an echo chamber and
surrounding yourself either only with
yes men in your own personal life or
certainly politically and culturally
surrounding yourself with people even if
they agree with you who won't challenge
you Gerald and I have gotten into some
knockdown drag out brawls mostly about
Transformers no one was over
soccer that's true you remember that's
true what what what was you said a power
lifter could run like a faster 40 yard
dash than like anybody on the planet I
was like what I said an Olympic lifter
Olympic LIF yeah and that's not true
it's not that's not what I said no I
know we we got to the was Olympic lifter
without later we figured it out yes
remember what I started yelling you have
you started yelling you have no science
have no science cuz I remember that
discussion we got into a big argument
and it was it was predicated on the idea
that soccer players are and so
no he meant fast he meant fast that's
what he meant no that's not what I meant
all but their hair stays in place I
meant I meant men who wear pink
jerseys and have buns in their hair
so we were talking about soccer
it was predicated on that and then he
was jald said they're the most they're
and this isn't even political but he
said they're actually some of the best
athletes in the world I said no not some
of the they're not no they're
not this is going to be the thing that
gets the most comments out of everything
we've discussed today right we've gotten
into Egyptian mythology the
conceptualization of Christ as opposed
to the literal interpretation we've
gotten into we've gotten into got gotten
into Thomas soul and what everyone's
going to come I can't believe that you
called p a
I that's like an old school
reference I mean you can't even come up
with like Rooney or somebody currents
you know no the ladies and
gentlemen see
this say are you saying man anyway so it
doesn't matter yeah well exactly Chelsea
Manhattan that is the area man Chelsea
man stop it just see see what happen
he's only ding his whole deeper but we
had this discussion and then afterwards
we had it we got into a big argument I
went to the bathroom took a leak and
then I came back we spent the rest of
the night we were totally fine yeah but
we got into an argument over it and I
remember what it was I was saying
actually there was a study the Olympic
lifters which actually you may be right
uh some people have tried to say this
was a falsified study wait wait now
maybe what I give it to you all King uh
they said it might be a falsified study
but this was a long time for a long time
accepted in sports training that the
Olympic lifters would actually outrun uh
some of the 100 meter Dashers or maybe
it was a 400 met like in up in the 10 uh
the 10 yards first like that explosive
off the blocks and it surprised a lot of
people and so they Incorporated a lot of
that sort of dynamic training into it
and so I was talking about that with
with soccer and and then we got into the
portion you where soccer just sucks as a
as a general
concept to
conceptualize soccer sucky so
the point
we got into this argument about it but
having a room full of people who still
feel comfortable questioning each other
and factchecking each other saying I
disagree with you on that is a much more
healthy atmosphere uh than I think you
even see in traditional media outlets
and you have to ask yourself we're
talking about the Golden Age of
Journalism to take it back to that what
do you think change if the Golden Age of
Journal same networks ABC NBC CBS
largely the same corporations or
certainly the same level of power of
these giant corporations so did it
change overnight where all of a sudden
everyone at NBC ABC CBS CNN most trusted
did it change overnight where all of a
sudden they decided we're only going to
hire liberals to the point where Chris
croma will go out there and actually
believe that he's a news anchor did that
happen overnight or is it maybe
something that was always there that you
weren't aware about because they've
always been in a room where they agree
with each other and you don't have you
will be amazed sometimes when you don't
have to accept this premise there are
some simple things sometimes people oh
and benj was very complimentary I do not
fancy myself a skilled debat at all like
I've said you know Thomas Soul uh Ben
Shapiro um even Jordan Peterson are
listen they're way more educated and
they're way more skilled in the art of
debate than I am for people who ask for
that if you're actually looking for
truth when you're having conversation
and a debate and you'll see this happen
with Chris Cuomo you'll see this happen
with a lot of members of traditional
media who were once respected if you
just check them on something very simple
that well Donald Trump hates immigrants
you can literally get the upper hand in
that conversation
in a conversation seeking the truth not
just talking about a debate well no no
hold on a second the problem we have is
with illegal immigration and you would
assume that they will be able to handle
that and Oh They'll have a counter
argument and then you'll have three or
four prepared which you always should
but most of the time it doesn't happen
certainly not with people uh who are
coming from the entertainment industry
or coming from the New York DC media
Elite it is remarkable where we've
gotten to a point where the most
rudimentary debating techniques or
skills the most rudimentary uh
employment of the Socratic method
destroys their entire basis uh of
arguing in the first place and you're
seeing that happen and this is a really
interesting time in history because I
don't think that this is the first time
people have woken up I don't think this
is the first time that people are
starting uh to be willing to to to
concede that I think it we're at a time
in history where people have been so
coddled where people in the
entertainment industry and people in the
media have been so used to like-minded
thinking and because of the information
Super Highway that is the internet
they're now being questioned on it and
you see it right you see like this is
why you see Chris Cuomo and Don Lemon
freaking out and getting into Twitter
fights like you make millions of dollars
every year and you're on one of the
biggest news networks in the world and
you're getting mad because someone said
that you're wrong on Twitter it's
because they're so fragile I don't think
they've been exposed to this information
as they've gotten from the Walking meme
on Twitter who just said as own Benjamin
said no 77 cents in the dollar is a lie
no it's illegal immigration and so I I
will say this if if nothing else to
learn it's okay to be bold sometimes
you'll be surprised have you ever had
this where you're getting into a
conversation or to an argument and
someone else says something that is sort
of assumed as the TR and they say it
confidently so you go well hold on a
second maybe they're right maybe I
shouldn't say what I thought I was going
to say because they seem confident about
that that's what's been going on for
decades in this country that's what's
been going on in ABC NBC CBS CNN every
every place that's what's been going on
with Sarah Silverman that's what's been
going on with Amy Schumer that's what's
been going on with the entertainment
industry they've been saying things
confidently enough that a lot of us have
been going well hold on a second 77 they
all say it it must be true you'd be
surprised as to how much Headway you can
make just by being bold in declaring
what you know to be true arm yourself
with information but if you know it to
be true and are just willing to speak
about it
publicly I've noticed this in my life
some people sometimes don't know how to
process it you'll be surprised so if
ever you're have to air in the side of
of of being Meek or being bold with
truth in speaking Truth uh try that this
week try speaking boldly truthfully and
uh I think you'll have a better week
because of it also I think you could
destroy Chris Cuomo so there's that see
you next
week it only takes a
[Music]
Time